Why don't we apply Mapreduce to our class projects?
This week, we're going to synthesize all of our findings up to this point,
the statistical analysis, the data driven predictions, and visualizations
into a blog post that your friends or family would be able to read if they
wanted to learn some interesting facts about the New York City subway system.
It's often helpful to begin a blog post with some interesting, but
basic facts about the subject you'll be discussing.
You might recall earlier in this course, I provided some statistics about
the New York City subway, like daily ridership, number of stops, ect.
I'd like you to collect some statistics, about our New York City subway data.
More specifically, how many subway riders were there,
over the course of May 2011?
And how many people passed through each station on an average day
using the Mapreduce programming model?